first off what does the word do room I
mean and when did you start writing it
so I actually started to write Daruma
after a member of my own family suffered
a spinal cord injury
they had a motorcycle accident and
became a two four five and six
paraplegic and I wrote this short as a
way to process my own grief I mean I you
know as a writer that's how I dealt with
my feelings it's I mean stead of stating
it I mean disability can affect anybody
at any given point in time I mean it is
it is a universal thing that everybody
deals with but I when I was at USC I
studied Asian art history for one of my
general requirement classes and one of
my classes we we studied this painting
called Iike showing his severed arm to
Daruma I didn't know anything about this
painting but it was written in the
Muromachi period by a guy named Sasha
Toyo it shows the Daruma which is the
Bodhidharma the guy that founded zen
buddhism now the legend goes is that he
meditated in a cave for nine years and
his limbs fell away he had no need for
them anymore so he was the sort of round
object you know I mean he had no no arms
and like nothing and the painting
depicts this guy named Iike who was a
would-be pupil a disciple who is so
desperate to study with the Daruma so
Iike severs his own arm and he presents
it to the Daruma and he wakes the Daruma
from a trance and the do room is like
you've missed the point of the lessons
and he turns them away and I was so
haunted by this painting because it was
so garish and it was it was just so ugly
but what happened was when my family
member was recovering from their injury
they you know spent months in
rehabilitation they were roomed with a
young man who had lost both of his arms
in an electrical accident and you know
they had both turned 21 and they both
had their lives ahead of them they were
both you know just just starting and you
could see you know the indomitable
spirit that they had you know they were
you know getting into all kinds of
mischief and stuff in the
every Center and they were still the
same people they had just had these
life-changing injuries but they were the
same people so this is where the idea of
Daruma came because here was one young
man who had just lost his arms and
here's a young another young man who had
just lost both of his legs so together I
you know the theme of this is you know
it becomes one person now if you look
online you will see what a Daruma doll
is now a Daruma doll is a round doll
that is popular in Japanese culture when
you get one you color in one eye black
and you make a wish when your wish comes
true you color in the other eye so you
know the the Daruma features as an
underlying theme in the story but the
story I wrote I wrote a fictionalized
version of this relationship that
unfolded so this is a story that follows
a very bitter angry paraplegic named
Patrick who discovers that he's got a
four year old daughter from a one-night
stand before he got injured and he takes
her for an insurance payout but he
quickly learns that he he can't parent
so he has to take her to live across the
country with her maternal grandparents
and the only person that can help him
make this journey his double arm amputee
so that's that's the the story of Daruma
and that's something that I've been
working on for a number of years now and
we have been connecting with
organizations like the Reeve Foundation
the rudder Minh Family Foundation
respectability we've been working with
those organizations to help build a
platform to get this story out you know
one of the things that I think was
shocking to me when I you know won the
contest and I got signed and I got
wrapped I thought you know this is that
I am I my screenwriting career is gonna
take off and that's not necessarily the
case you still have to be your own
advocate and you still have to be
prepared to pursue your passion projects
because not everybody is going to see
the vision that you have for something
now we're fortunate and that we
have you know the team with Daruma has
you know we've partnered with people who
have seen the vision
we're authentically casting these roles
we are we are casting two disabled
actors to play these these lead roles I
don't want to have a situation where
we've got an able-bodied actor who can
you know play a disabled rule that's not
what we're setting out to do so it's
it's an uphill battle to produce this
project but we're doing a crowdfunding
October first we see the spark which is
an indie filmmaker platform and I
encourage anybody who has a script or
they want to shoot a concept and they
don't know where to go look there look
at other projects look at what other
people are doing it's a great place to
connect with other filmmakers - yeah
they have some fantastic campaigns and
you have a website that's already set up
for Daruma I do I do actually and I
think one of the most interesting things
about that website is that we have put
content from other sources like
respectability and the Ford Foundation
they all have toolkits for disability
inclusion in Hollywood so as a writer we
talked about sensitivity reads earlier
these they're PDFs that you can download
from the website they actually have
different tips and steps that you as a
writer or a producer or a filmmaker can
draw from and put into your own work and
I think it's great to that you already
have your website ready to go I mean I
saw some of the cast yeah yeah and your
director and his bio and your bio yep so
I think that's great so many people I
know they don't it's not ready yet and
you know I think it's great because you
but right now it's August and you know
have a few months and that I mean it's
fully fleshed out website looks great
well we actually put that website up and
almost a year and a half ago oh you did
oh yeah that websites been up for a
while one of the things that we've
learned about this process is that
nobody's gonna do it for you you have to
be able to and I mean this is where I
put my producer hat on you have to be
able to just draw that line in the sand
and be like a peg this is it we're going
and I find that when you start to get
people to to come on board one of the
and one day I'm gonna write a book about
this one one day this is gonna be my my
book to filmmaking but do you know the
story about fulfill our Stone Soup shel
silverstein no no it's actually it's a
it's a it's a old folk folktale
there's a man who wanders into a village
and he's hungry and nobody will help him
and all of it'll just all the villagers
turn away so I think all right well I
have a rock so he goes to the center of
town and he's like I have a magic Rock
this magic Rock will make amazing soup
for everybody to eat he's like well in
order to get started I just need a
little bit of water so someone's like
all right I'll buy into this I'll get me
a little bit of water
is that okay well great so now that we
have this water in this magic Rock we
just need a little bit of fire so
there's our lie about some woods all
contribute some wood and gradually
everybody starts contributing to this
pot and they make this amazing soup so
if you look at the process of making an
independent feature like we're doing
with Daruma as sort of making a film
soup you you start to look at you know
you bring this to the table and it go
well I can bring this to the table and
you start building a team and a
collaboration and eventually you get to
the point where we are where you you
know we did the website then we did a
casting and we connected with you know
casting directors and agents and we
started to actually cast you know
disabled actors and the lead roles and
that opened up the doors says other
community and now we're partnering with
organizations and it's one thing on top
of it another and it's it's very easy to
get discouraged in this process because
it takes a long time but honestly these
things should take a long time they
should because they they need to be good
they they're important so that's really
interesting so that you don't want to
rush it because it means a lot to you
and so just putting it out and it's half
done and then there's criticisms and you
go yeah I know that's that's smart I
mean it's it's one thing to wait for
something to happen and then it's
another to be like you know what it's
it's time it's it's finding a balance so
we we could wait forever and you know
look for the right you know financers to
to come and give us money to make this
project the
the fact that matters is that casting to
lead actors to you know that have
disabilities that's not really something
people want to take a gamble on that's
not something you know a lot of people
you know as a producer or you know film
financier or whatever would be like well
what's who's who's your lead actor
because their job is to make money you
know they've got they've got to pay
their bills they've got a you know kids
to send to school or whatever it's not a
risk that people are necessarily willing
to take but that doesn't mean that the
project shouldn't be made so it's up to
you to find creative ways to make it
happen
and you're also the writer a writer and
so you said it's loosely based on a
family member it's not their exact story
no it's not it's not loosely based on
them at all oh no no my this family
member never discovered that they had a
child from a one-night stand it's it's
it was written as a way for me to
process my own grief what was very
important for me about this particular
story if you look at most narratives
where you have a disabled character the
the storyline tends to go from being
able bodied to having a tragic accident
and then suddenly being disabled and
then living your life you know then
that's that's the inspirational part of
the story it was very important for me
to tell a story where it had two leads
that were disabled and that that wasn't
a plot point that wasn't a device it's
nothing for them to overcome it just is
what it is because listen 25 percent of
the American population lives with a
disability yet two percent are
represented on screen
hmm so we talked about you know using
your privilege as a platform for
underrepresented voices this is single
handedly for me the most important
project that I'm working on right now
you